the Ouija board is probably the most
successful and recognizable object that
came out of the Age of spiritualism in
this country it's exactly the kind of
object that American spiritualist were
attracted to because it had this
do-it-yourself quality in the 1850s
1860s American spiritualists who
believed ardently and what they were
doing had an ideal that eventually
talking to the dead would be as
effortless and as ordinary as dinnertime
conversation so they set themselves to
the task of figuring out how could this
be accomplished what method could we use
they experimented with trance mediumship
automatic writing there was a little
plank called the planchette which is
French for a little plank that was used
you would sort of pencil into it it was
a little triangular table on ball
bearings that was used for automatic
writing and eventually spiritualists hit
on to something they call the alphabet
board or the talking board this is what
became the Ouija board the earliest
image of the Ouija board appeared in the
New York Herald Tribune in the year 1886
there was an article about spiritualists
in northern Ohio who were just entranced
with this thing that they called the
talking board that was supposed to be
the easiest method yet for speaking to
the other side and the newspaper
featured a couple of drawings one of
them was just a little Mac's
matchbox size drawing of the Ouija board
and is the spitting image of the board
that we know today they also showed a
man and a woman using the talking board
balancing it together on their knees
which is important because the the
talking board or the Ouija board was
also a very flirtatious experience for
people in the Victorian era it gave men
and women an excuse to sit knee to knee
maybe even join hands while they were
consulting this magical board now the
interesting thing is the Ouija board was
a homemade invention it's it's it's it's
the earliest record of it probably is in
Ohio as seen in this 1886 newspaper
report less than five years later there
were a group of novelty manufacturers in
the city of Baltimore who seized upon
the board and man
to get a federal patent on it so they
got their patent and they called it the
Ouija board the name is a source of
mystery everybody has different stories
about where it came from nobody really
knows but the invention just the the
object just took off it's spread across
the country people were enthralled with
it it became so popular that by 1922 the
artist Norman Rockwell painted a satire
of a man and woman using the Ouija board
which appeared on the cover of The
Saturday Evening Post and if you look at
Rockwell satire you see basically the
same image that appeared back in 1886
the man and woman with their knees kind
of bumping using the Ouija board
together it's in Rockwell's painting
it's it's sort of weaving this little
flirtatious spell around them in 1966
the original baltimore family that
manufactured the Ouija board sold it to
Parker Brothers and when Parker Brothers
marketed the board for the first time
the following year in 1967 it actually
outsold Monopoly that's how popular the
Ouija board was at that time and the
late 60s saw an occult revival sweeping
through the nation the the Woodstock
generation was not only open to eastern
religious ideas but they were open to
all kinds of occult ideas that were
coming out of the age of spiritualism
that were coming from 19th century
movements in this country one of them
was called the theosophy movement which
which had helped repopulate concepts in
the late 19th century so the late 60s
saw an occult revival the Ouija board
was at the ready and young people
embraced it
Ouija circles sprang up in dormitories
and interestingly enough very often it
was women who were conducting the
nightly Regis sessions which unbeknownst
to them was a reenactment of
spiritualism from the mid 19th century
Parker Brothers and manufacturers it
does not seem terribly interested to
talk about the board they continue to
manufacture it but last time I went on
their website they didn't post a history
of the Ouija board even though they have
histories for twister and the game of
life and other very storied products
that they sell people are scared of
Ouija they don't want to attract
boycotts from the Christian right they
don't want to attract somebody who's
going to commit some kind of a crime and
claim well the Ouija board told me to do
it that's part of its history we never
seem to have been able to digest the
Ouija board because it is an object from
the Age of spiritualism that has made it
into slumber parties and basements and
toy rooms all across the country and yet
there's this very frightening and weird
urban mythology around the Ouija board
ask anyone and they have some strange
story of being a kid and using the Ouija
board and the lights flicked on and off
where they heard mysterious or ghostly
knocks at their door there are some
people in a cult history who warned
against using the Ouija board who said
this is a dangerous door to the
unconscious don't approach this thing so
we like to make fun of it we're sort of
frightened of it there's nostalgia
around it but the fact is in some ways
it reflects the success of spiritualism
well the most common explanation that
you'll find is that it's it's just a
tool of auto suggestion we are just
using it to act out communications from
our deepest unconscious there are
serious psychical researchers who looked
at the Ouija board in the 1960s and that
was the conclusion they came up with it
says reasonable conclusion as any except
when you talk to people who use it and
you know you hear about the events they
describe they'll have none of it so it
seems to be an object that's just going
to withhold its mysteries from us